hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry so
today we're checking out the gameplay
trailer release of III that a lot of
people are asking me to check this out
horizon zero dawn no knowledge of this
game at all I believe this is original
and it's not like some established
franchise I want to establish up front
I've never said like I'm the most gaming
knowledgeable guy what I'm gonna do is
have a little hobby channel on the side
called this is gonna be literally just
like a hobby channel not going to be
something I'm like uploading all the
time on call gaming rejects
where I'll be doing let's places I'm
going to be getting ps4 soon and I'm
going to be catching up on games but I
want to keep the real rejects more of a
movie channel based movie and TV show
based because I don't want this to
become a gaming channel just saying that
up front that's why you're not seeing as
many trailer reviews for games these
days trying to keep a tone established
oh hey sorry
[ __ ] [ __ ] always [ __ ] calls me
little [ __ ] video [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
Seth
[Music]
from Sony boy howdy
- paintings or need
we know we weren't the first ones here
the Indians our stories sneak of the
ones that came before
the old ones
ah the world of the old ones was so
different than ours we had built
incredible cities with towers and
reached the stars when darkness came
and their students
turn to great
[Music]
I started to change
the great cities faded away it's
beautiful
everything became beautiful again and in
their place
a new life
over time
the tribes came to these lands it's so
small and humble
powerful as king
they say my tribe was the first first to
hurt
the first to raise our bows
[Music]
dangerous the tool now and was shewn
I interesting this is a really pretty
I'm lovin it
Keibler
I got a winter of I'm about it
[Music]
or door
[Music]
yeah
perfect Wow
now this one kitchen [ __ ] way cool
this is going to be harder than I
thought
[Music]
look again here sarcastic
yeah
that thing's pretty [ __ ]
[Music]
nice
nice nice
is fast
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
this has got any order the coolest
things I've ever seen
I love it
[Music]
time to shut
[Music]
this is a nice surprise she's awesome
she's hot the stories don't tell or the
old ones went they don't tell us why the
machine was one of these lands
they warn us
sounds canalized
[Music]
damn
Rob and I will be right well I wish that
was part of that crowd hasn't awesome
that was awesome and the world of it was
you see a lot of King games with the
post-apocalyptic world or a you know
alternate modern day but this or
alternate history alternate paths yeah
this was a one of the more interesting
concepts I've seen a post-apocalyptic
world just in general because it starts
off like okay we're with Indians I'm
gonna stalk like an idiot right now
just to get my point across faster look
whoever Indians and then oh this is
actually the future where the world has
fallen apart and then nature has taken
over but it's like a hybrid of like
before oh is it that is it's so far in
the few yeah I remember saying like past
cities and stuff and then they're gonna
she's going to the lands and the ruins
and it's all the the nature grew above
it did you not catch any of that did you
watch the train I guess I guess for some
reason like I saw her because they
introduced it to us in a cave with cave
paintings I was like oh this must be a
long time ago and then yeah then she is
so it's the Seas the future but it's us
that she's talking about and then when
we died out nature took back over now
there okay so now it's a hybrid so it's
not a long time ago no it's not like a
long time ago alternate past its
geography gotcha
cuz like I love that because it's a cool
hybrid of before technology and when
technology is at its highest you know so
you got both of those things combined
you got cool type of gameplay where
you're fighting like a like a badass
Indian chick oh and arrow and all kinds
of [ __ ] that she has on her you know but
it looks awesome and it's cool to have
you know badass chick in the driver's
seat
oh yeah plus you know bow and arrow is a
nice break from guns it's just a really
cool world that one has to be a part of
just at least once you know
oh yeah the main character seems fun I
like their reactions to things just kind
of got that Drake Uncharted personality
but
Indian hunting [ __ ] I really like these
sort of like clash of you know science
fiction and time periods and stuff like
that and I really I really want to play
this like I haven't gotten to play game
a long time but I would love to pick
this up
it's very thematic very Tim attic is the
word right sure themed attic thematic
how you saying I don't wanna be in a
tannic cuz these names it's yeah see
sure one sure it's thematic its thematic
it has themes yeah that's one that's my
point
semantics again that's a word yeah it's
visually gorgeous everything a battle
looks gray of course I'm gonna check
this game out brand new sought to feel
like a pathetic 16 other [ __ ] games
together yeah anyway thanks guys for
saying that was out if you're new to the
Chanel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can catch Ariane reasons to
Jerry and dank ass dubs you could follow
us on Facebook Instagram Twitter and
vine because we want more money from
more product placement because we're
going to put it back into the channel
like we up our production quality we do
reactions people